Before Buffy Summers
and Indiana Jones,
before Superman
and Ellen Ripley,
before Robin Hood,
King Arthur and Beowulf,
or Rey Skywalker, Achilles,
and Katniss Everdeen,
there was the original
hero's journey
and quite possibly the
oldest known story ever told,
"The Epic of Gilgamesh."
Written around 5,000 years ago
in what is now Iraq,
the Mesopotamian
myth of Gilgamesh
has become the gold standard
against which folklore
heroes have been measured.
And his story contains many
of the foundational
tropes of mythology.
Even if you've never
read a Gilgamesh legend,
his battles with monsters,
squabbles with gods,
journeys to other worlds,
and general agonizing
about what it means
to be a hero will
probably look familiar.
But these storytelling devices
were cutting edge at the time
and copied over and over again.
Even though these
narrative beats hail
from a time that feels
so unlike our own,
Gilgamesh's inner journey
still feels relevant today.
When we look closely at his
errors, his relationships,
and his character
transformations,
it's clear that he's so much
more than a mythical blueprint.
[bright music]
We first meet Gilgamesh
as the beautiful brutal leader
of the Sumerian city of Uruk.
He's kind of a toxic bro
who likes getting into
brawls and seducing brides
on their wedding nights.
The goddess Aruru finally
gets sick of Gil's antics
and mixes up some spit and clay
to create a powerful adversary
for him, Harry Wildman.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I read that wrong.
I mean a hairy
wild man named Enkidu,
sometimes depicted as
half bull, half man
with superhuman strength, but
an innocent heart, like Gronk.
Enkidu skulks outside
the city walls,
eating grass and
befriending animals,
before striding into the
city to challenge Gilgamesh
to a fight.
The two appear to
be evenly matched
as they wrestle
across the city,
until Gilgamesh
eventually triumphs.
After duking it out, their
rivalry turns to mutual respect.
You're good, Gilgamesh.
I'll give you that.
You too, Enkidu. Hoo.
Wanna truce?
Sure.
You know what? Maybe we should,
like, join up forces.
We'd probably be
better together.
Oh, I love that.
You know, I've always
wanted a sidekick.
Oh, great.
Wait, what?
Despite their differences,
from that day onwards,
the two are inseparable.
Wait, that reminds me
of something.
[encouraging music]
Enkidu's innocence and
communion with nature
make him a foil for Gilgamesh's
excessive tendencies,
but their relationship
is more intimate
than your run-of-the-mill
hero-sidekick dynamic.
You could call it
the original bromance.
But many have viewed
Gilgamesh and Enkidu
as a homoerotic or
queer love story
in which the two
provide each other
with much-needed
companionship and care.
Their relationship is described
as a marriage in numerous
passages of the epic,
and it's the first time
we see Gilgamesh caring
about someone
other than himself.
Gilgamesh even confides
his deepest desire
to his new companion:
to achieve lasting fame.
This was a lot harder
to do before YouTube.
So together they embark on a
series of rebellious escapades.
Chopping down
a sacred cedar forest,
murdering the many-headed
guardian of the cedars,
and killing the
sacred Bull of Heaven.
God forbid he should try to
get famous by, I don't know,
planting a cedar forest
or healing a sacred bull.
Well, the gods didn't
like it either.
As punishment, they strike
Enkidu with a terminal illness
and he dies in Gilgamesh's arms.
Wait, what?
Enkidu was the nice one.
All this chopping and killing
for fame was Gilgamesh's idea.
But Enkidu's death
provides an opportunity
for Gilgamesh to grow.
How nice for Gilgamesh.
He realizes he's been going
about things all wrong.
His goal shouldn't be
fame, but immortality.
Aim high, I guess.
Gilgamesh wanders
across the wilderness
in search of Utnapishtim,
a wise man who had been
granted immortality by the gods
as a reward for saving humanity
from a cataclysmic flood
by building a giant ark.
What does that remind me of?
Deucalion?
No.
Vivos vita?
Bergelmir?
No.
Forget it.
To find Utnapishtim, Gilgamesh
must pass through Mashu,
a mountain rooted
in the underworld
and towering towards heaven.
Its guardians, a pair
of scorpion warriors,
warn him that no light touches
the passage through Mashu.
After hours of total
darkness and howling winds,
Gilgamesh emerges into
a glittering garden.
Beyond the garden
lies the Sea of Death,
and there on the shore is a bar.
But instead of Tom Cruise
in a Hawaiian shirt,
this bar is tended by
the divine alewife, Siduri.
Like any good bartender, Siduri
listens to Gilgamesh's woes
and gives him some smart advice.
"Quit this wild goose chase
and just enjoy what's left
of your short mortal life."
Does that sound like something
our Gilgamesh would do?
Heck no.
He ignores her and sails
to Utnapishtim's island
where he begs the old man
for the secret to immortality.
Utnapishtim also thinks
Gil's mission is boneheaded,
but, like a divine
reality show host,
offers him a couple
physical challenges.
First, if he can stay awake
for seven days straight,
the gods might grant
him immortality.
That's it?
This is the guy who chopped
down the sacred cedars
and hunted the Bull of Heaven.
Staying awake should
be no problem at...
Oh. Oh yeah, he falls asleep.
Next, he must retrieve
a magical youth-giving plant
from the bottom of the ocean,
which gets snatched right out
of his hands by a snake.
Dejected and defeated,
Gilgamesh finally gives up
on his dreams and heads home.
But there, a profound
character shift occurs.
The specifics vary depending
on which version you're reading.
Maybe he settles down
and starts a family.
Maybe he focuses on being
a good leader and city builder,
or maybe he pursues wisdom and
writes about his adventures.
Whatever the details,
Gilgamesh comes to accept
his human limitations
and, like the gods had been
pushing him to do all along,
make the most of his
limited time on earth.
This is still a massively
popular narrative device.
How many heroes set off in
pursuit of fame and riches
only to learn that
the real treasure
is the friends we
made along the way?
Gilgamesh set the
standard for real heroes
knowing when to give up on
fame and glory and just...
Let it go.
Gilgamesh's decision to write
about his life is also
a popular hero trope
with particular meaning
for the Sumerian people.
Gilgamesh's domain, Uruk,
was a real place that grew
into a vast urban center
during the 4th millennium BCE
and is considered by many to
be the world's first real city.
Bureaucracy and finance
increased the demand for writers
who kept records and
tracked resources,
but also put oral
stories to tablet.
Written in cuneiform,
the oldest known
form of writing,
"The Epic of Gilgamesh" is one
of the earliest
works of literature
that testifies in numerous ways
to the enduring human
desire to make our mark.
In that way, Gilgamesh did
kind of achieve immortality.
Maybe instead of sending him
to the bottom of the sea,
Utnapishtim should have just
handed him a chisel and tablet
and sent him home.
Now it's time for another
one of our Pantheon Picks.
This is something new
we're doing this season.
Dr. Z and I are each going
to choose different figures
from mythology that we love
and we're going to join them
in a united pantheon at
the end of this season.
I made my first pick
in the first episode
of the season,
and now it is Dr. Z's turn.
For a Mesopotamian
mythology episode
and probably the least
surprising pick of all time,
I'm going with Tiamat.
What?
I know! Shocking from
the monster expert.
Tiamat is considered
a mother by some people now,
but she was a creation
deity originally.
She literally housed
all of creation
in Mesopotamian
mythology in her womb.
And I think like a warm,
squishy waterbed
of creation sounds
like a nice option
to have to relax in the utopia.
She can create life,
and also could help us
defending the utopia
against anyone
trying to attack us.
If we need to make
some kind of weird
Pegasus-weather demon hybrid,
she's got the experience.
Oh, brilliant choice.
I love that.
And you're right,
I'm not surprised
but your justification
is perfect, immaculate,
great choice.
(Emily)
Thank you.
Before you go, PBS has
several new documentary series
over on PBS Voices.
And if you haven't seen
them, now's the time.
"Ritual" explores the
history of unique customs
from across the American South.
"Dead and Buried"
reexamines our society's
relationship with death
and "Brave Spaces" spotlights
LGBTQ communities
standing strong
in the face of adversity.
We've got links in
the description.
We hope you check 'em out and
let us know what you think.
(director)
Or, sorry. Right.
-Okay.
-Let's start from the top.
[singing]
Let it go!
(director)
I mean, even though
you won, Gilgamesh...
Okay, cut.